this is kind of a scary story did you
know this it turns out the FDA Food and
Drug Administration has been approving
drugs faster than ever while all the
time relying on weaker and weaker
evidence and less testing that's really
happening it's terrifying the FDA is
just approving drugs pop hazard Lee
willy-nilly sorry no one said that on TV
in 15 years and I just wanted it was a
personal challenge for me
really it's crazy they'll approve
anything these days check out some of
the new medications that have just been
released it's crazy tylenol triple
extreme may cause external bleeding look
at this one vitamin L they don't even
know yeah look at this horse strength
imodium there's equal goodbye your final
sleep check this one out seven to one
odds birth control
there's Pfizer combination stool
softener and urine stiffener there's
Rogaine wherever just anywhere there's
little plumpers cialis for kids
that one bothered you that I'm getting
get in the sense I'm gonna say it again
it's little plumpers cialis for kids
there's sudafed margarita mix and
finally vag a max vagina enlargement
pills
[Applause]